yesterday you may have heard that
President Trump tweeted about the need
for good border security except he
spelled it BOA rder
like cupboard or snowboard and that
actually got me thinking it got the it
got the creative juices flowing and
before you know it I had this whole idea
for a blockbuster film that was all
based on this one typo and it may seem
kind of weird to base a movie on a typo
but they based movies on a lot of dumb
things these days so why not on a on a
typo so here's my idea just very quickly
at the top and if you know any Hollywood
producers and you could pass this along
this is my idea okay just just just
imagine this the movie is called border
security spelled Trump's way Bo AR D er
and it stars the rock as an elite
snowboarder recruited by the government
to guard in Mountain military
institution against an army of
genetically modified yetis okay of
course Kevin Hart will will be his
sidekick in the movie I don't have all
the scenes and dialogue worked out yet
but I need a lot of snow puns in the
movie and then I need a scene at the end
of the movie where where the rock is
battling the head Yeti guy and he
finally wins the altercation and he's
about to throw the Yeti into an oncoming
avalanche and then he says something
like says something like I think you
need to cool down and then he throws me
which I know that that kind of
plagiarizes aren't Swartz and Egger in
Batman Forever but but but that's fine
and if the rock is not available for
this film then we can change it a little
bit and it could be Liam Neeson as a
grizzled ex snowboarder who has to come
out of retirement to rescue his
kidnapped daughter from a gang of eskimo
human traffickers and I definitely need
a scene in that movie like like the Ben
Hur chariot racing except with sled dogs
so anyway that's I'm just that's that's
my idea
Hollywood and I'm throwing it out there
for free I will only need five million
dollars it's free except for the five
million dollars that I would need if you
decide to make that movie alright um a
lot I want to discuss today
ben shapiro has an inn
resting peace in the daily wire about a
professor at Clemson philosophy
professor Todd may is his name and he
wrote an article in The New York Times
called wood human extinction be a
tragedy so you know this is gonna be
good and it shouldn't be good it
shouldn't be a good article it shouldn't
be interesting because it should be a
really short article what human
extinction be a tragedy that's the title
and then the body of the article is yes
the end that's what it should be right
because it's a very obvious answer and
then but that that would be an odd
article to put in a newspaper so he has
more to say than that and as I'm sure
you can imagine he he is not so sure
that it would actually be a tragedy
basically he concludes that human
extinction would be a tragedy from a
human perspective but it would also
potentially be a good thing and he goes
on to explain that humans are cruel and
barbaric and so on and we're destroying
the planet and we're killing animals and
maybe the world would be better without
us here's here's the segment here's one
segment of his article that been quotes
it says to make that case let me start
with a claim that I think will be at
once depressing and upon reflection
uncontroversial human beings are
destroying large parts of the
inhabitable earth and causing
unimaginable suffering to many of the
animals that inhabit it this is
happening through at least three means
first human contribution to climate
change
second increasing human populations
encroaching on ecosystems that would
otherwise be intact third factory
farming fosters the creation of millions
upon millions of animals for whom it
offers nothing but suffering and misery
before slaughtering them in often
barbaric ways there is no reason to
think that those practices are going to
diminish anytime soon quite the opposite
humanity then is the source of
devastation of the lives of unconscious
animals I should say on a scale that is
difficult to comprehend if this were all
if this were all to the story there
would be no tragedy the elimination of
the human species would be a good thing
full stop now may acknowledges that
at poetry and art this guy teaches at a
college by the way may acknowledges that
poetry and art and and so on are good
but he says that all the misery we bring
to animals and plants outweighs that and
then he gets to his proposal and I like
that he offers a solution because I'm a
solution oriented guy but actually I'm
not all I do is complain about society
so I'm a complaint oriented guy but he
is a solution oriented guy and that's
and that's good but his solution is a
little problematic his solution is
potentially mass suicide or killing all
the babies that's his solution he says
one might ask whether given this view it
would also be a good thing for those of
us who are currently here to end our
lives in order to prevent further animal
suffering although I do not have a final
answer to this question I have a final
answer to it I'm not going to commit
suicide for this so that squirrels and
cows don't suffer that's my answer so I
have no problem answering that quote my
answer is no I'm not going so if
everybody gets together and says hey
Matt we're gonna have a mass suicide you
know for the sake of the horses my
answer is gonna be no thank you I I
appreciate the invitation very polite of
you but I'm actually I'm going to go
watch TV instead although I don't have a
final answer this question we should
recognize that the case of future humans
is very different from the case of
currently existing humans to demand to
demand of currently existing humans that
they should end their lives would
introduce significant suffering among
those who have much to lose by dying in
contrast preventing future humans from
existing does not introduce such
suffering since those human beings will
not exist and therefore not have lives
to sacrifice the two situations then are
not analogous it may well be then that
the extinction of humanity would make
the world better off and yet would be a
tragedy I don't want to say this for
sure since the issue is quite complex
but it certainly seems a live
possibility and that by itself disturbs
me says may yes it does
me too it disturbs me that you teach at
a college though this is exactly what I
would expect from a college professor
and from the New York Times it's exactly
and there's a reason why this is from a
college professor in The New York Times
and there it's crazy for one thing you
expect crazy things from college
professors these days but it also it
also shows you that this is a pretty
mainstream view on the left a mainstream
attitude I should say now the exact
proposal of well maybe we should all
kill ourselves
if not we'll kill the babies you know
that exact proposal may not be accepted
by everybody on the left but the
attitude the general nihilistic attitude
that humans are a blight on the earth
that is definitely mainstream in fact I
could I doubt you could find very many
people on the Left who would
substantially disagree with it I doubt
you could find that but there's a
problem here okay well there's many
problems but I'm just gonna deal with
the logical problems the moral problems
of mass suicide of or killing babies the
moral problems there are so obvious that
either you see them or you're way too
deluded to be convinced by a guy on
Facebook so I'm just gonna leave that to
the side let's talk about the logical
problems with this rather nihilistic
approach specifically specifically with
the approach that says the earth will be
better off without humans okay now
number one if you believe in God well
now we are getting into the moral aspect
I guess but if you believe in God then
obviously it makes no sense to say that
the planet is better off without humans
because in that case the planet was
largely made maybe not not only maybe
not solely but was largely made for
humans now so then of course it doesn't
make any sense that we're
not being on the planet that was was
made for us if you don't believe in God
and I assume that this professor doesn't
if he's entertaining the possibility
that we should all kill ourselves then I
assume he doesn't believe in God but if
you don't believe we got then it makes
even less sense to have this kind of
attitude because there's no basis by
which to call a human list planet good
or better
there's no these are value judgments
these are moral value judgments and from
the godless perspective moral value is a
human construct so if there are no
humans then there are no moral values
nature cannot see itself as good and
there's no indication that animals have
any moral sense whatsoever
so in order for the earth to be good in
order for it to be better there there
must be human beings on it and then
you're left with a paradox that in order
for the earth to be better off without
humans there have to be humans around to
declare that it's better off otherwise
it's just it's just nothing in in a
morally relativistic world that means
that humans come up with the idea of
morality if there are no humans around
there's no morality it's just it's just
existence it makes no sense to call it
better good worse anything you can't you
can't use any of those terms whatsoever
the second thing is I see I see in this
logic the same flaw that I see in
vegetarianism ok if you're going to say
that it's it's wrong for us to kill
animals for instance that what are you
basing that on are you saying that we're
all equal to animals thus we have no
right to kill them but if that's the
case then why are you expecting more out
of us than you expect out of other
animals if we're equal to them animals
kill each other all the time animals eat
other species they eat the same species
they
eat their young they eat their mates
they kill oh they kill each other over
territory etc so if we're equal to
animals then there's no reason at all to
oppose us killing animals because we're
just acting like we are just being one
of them
the fact that we're so much better at it
the fact that you know we're more
efficient and better at killing and
killing animals that doesn't that
doesn't mean anything if if if lions
could could kill their prey in an in a
more effective efficient way they would
they just are too stupid to have figured
it out we figured it out so there's no
so again if we're equal to animals there
is it makes no sense at all to say that
we shouldn't kill and eat animals in
that case because that's what animals do
right and in that case in fact if we're
equal to animals then it's kind of
presumptuous not to kill any animals I
think it's it's almost if we're equal to
them it's almost rude not to kill and
eat them because it's presumptuous it's
like we're pretending to be better than
them or something it we're taking this
kind of like holier than now approach
and I'm sure if the cows could speak
they would say dude you're not better
than me okay who do you think you are
and then we would say yeah you're right
you know what I guess we should eat you
that's how that conversation would go
but if you say that we shouldn't kill
animals because we are superior to
animals we are rational we know better
then I could take that same logic and I
could say that our superiority gives us
the right to use animals to our benefit
so either way you know either were equal
or were superior to them and whichever
one is the case it just doesn't make
logical sense at that point to say that
it's wrong to kill and eat them now
granted this article only specifically
takes issue with factory farming and I
grant that you could take issue with
factory farming while being okay with
eating meat otherwise so I'm just
talking about vegetarianism in general
here but I still think that my point
lies to this particular argument because
he says that we may be better off
killing ourselves partly for the sake of
the animals but if we're equal to the
animals that our domination of the
planet is perfectly natural and
perfectly normal and it's perfectly
animalistic which is what you would
expect from animals it's exactly what
the dinosaurs did though in a different
form but they dominated the planet and
and in many ways made it inhospitable to
other forms of life as they were the you
know as the age of the dinosaurs for
millions of years and they they they
were the dominating force now they were
wiped out by an asteroid but but nobody
would say nobody would say that you know
they should have all killed themselves
because they weren't giving other forms
of life a chance so if we are superior
to animals then again it makes no sense
to call for our extinction now we could
go on all day dissecting the problems
with with this logic the real point is
simply that there are people in America
who really do think this way ok really
do think like this who really do see
humankind as a curse on the planet and
you notice that these people are never
willing to go first they aren't going to
remove themselves from the gene pool and
get the ball rolling no they want others
to do it just like the people who
complain about overpopulation you'll
notice they complain about
overpopulation but they never seem to
put themselves in the over category
right there just population everybody
else is overpopulation or more more
commonly the over are the babies and the
unborn babies they're the ones who are
extra that's kind of the the the
attitude that this article takes as well
which brings us to a whole other problem
ok if you're going to say that we are
some ways equal to animals and we should
value animal life even plant life then
how do you not apply that logic to
unborn babies because you can't there's
no question that unborn babies are
living there there's no doubt about that
they are they are living creatures and
if you're going to extol the the value
of animal life then you can't make
rationality the basis by which a
creature is is is accorded value if
because in that case then animals aren't
worth anything either so an unborn baby
is is a living creature so then in that
case what and why penalize them you know
you notice his argument this is so
common on the Left where they say well
you know we need abortion because of
overpopulation humans are destroying the
planet
why are unborn children penalized for
that they didn't do it okay so you're
not blaming the cows and you're not
blaming the squirrels or whatever for
for destroying the planet you'd say well
they didn't do it it's not their fault
fine well the unborn children didn't do
it either why do they have to pay the
price it doesn't make any sense and if
you're talking about what we need to
make the planet a better place for the
sake of animals yeah what about making
the planet a better place for the sake
of our children well what about this is
making a better place for the sake of
our unborn I mean you're worried about
you're worried about how the planet is
for for deer and foxes and and Chipmunks
but you're not worried about how the
planet will be for our children no for
our children you say yeah well we'll
just get what kill them we'll get rid of
them but you know we need we need to
really fix things for the sake of for
the sake of aardvarks it's just it is a
it is not only a morally deranged point
of view it is completely and totally
illogical all right an article on The
Daily wire yesterday by Amanda
presto Giacomo by the way I saw her at
the Christmas party and I asked her how
to pronounce her last name because you
know I used her articles all the time
for my show but I could never quote her
because I wasn't sure to pronounce the
last name I did want to pronounce it
wrong because she was a co-worker so I
got the right pronounce pronunciation so
now I could finally give her credit
anyway
article says on December 1st an 11 year
old boy dressed in drag danced on stage
in a sexual manner at a gay bar in
Brooklyn called $3 bill the child
Desmond Napoli's orna poles was dressed
as a Gwen Stefani look-alike full drag
makeup a blonde wig a crop top as he
bounced around on stage to no doubts
like a girl and collected dollar bills
from male adults viewing the number this
is not made up okay this is this this
happened
The Daily wire has reviewed the the
reviewed and confirmed the performance
through video and photo posts on social
media but has chosen not to link to the
exploitative footage the performance
first flagged by youtuber Yosef Isaiah
was promoted on Eventbrite by three
dollar bill the promotion says only in
New York a nightclub that makes you go
whoa reads the promotion featuring
upcoming legend from television in the
runway Desmond is amazing performing
live this stage this dancefloor this
house is ours as long as we protect it
so the article goes on from there the
boy has been on the drag circuit he
appeared in a drag and I think in a
appeared in some kind of drag music
video when he was 6 years old his family
as you may have guessed is totally
supportive they would have to be because
as a child doesn't get involved with
this kind of stuff unless you're putting
them into it right a six-year-old boy
should have no clue what what what what
a drag queen is
six-year-old boy I should have no idea
what it means to dress in drag so if
your six-year-old boy is into that it's
because you introduced him to it and got
him into it because you are a a pervert
and a deranged nutcase and they also
appear to have monetized their son's
sexual exploitation they have
merchandise now among other things now
what what can I say about this that I
haven't already said what we're seeing
here is child sexual abuse plain and
simple obviously the parent should be in
jail so should the owners of this bar so
should everybody who knowingly attended
the drag performance of a child but
mainly the parents the parents are
sexually exploiting their own child in
plain view of everyone and rather than
being arrested
rather than being condemned they are
applauded and celebrated now there's
there's just one additional point I want
to make about this and I've talked about
this kind of thing many times but I want
you to imagine for a moment okay imagine
that this was an 11 year old girl being
paraded around all dolled up dancing
onstage with a bunch of men at a bar
throwing dollar bills at her okay just
just imagine that imagine it is a it is
a girl dressed in the way the drag
queens dress dancing on stage and there
are a bunch of men hooting and hollering
and throwing dollar bills that are now
of course there is no moral difference
at all between that situation and this
there is not even the slightest smallest
difference it is exactly the same thing
and yet if there were a video of
something like that happening there
would be national outrage everybody
involved would be arrest
on sex abuse charges and deservedly so
and we all know it who who in the world
would stand up to defend something like
that no this is only tolerated because
it's a boy with gay men that's the fact
and as much as the LGBT community likes
to complain about persecution the truth
is that they get special treatment as
always right because they can get away
with pretty much anything because
everyone is so deathly afraid of being
called homophobic you know that's the
that's the that is the that is the one
label that's the one thing that nobody
wants to be stuck with nobody wants to
be a homophobe and so we're just gonna
if we look at was how well it's the gay
community doing it that means that we
can't we can't complain
we can't criticize it well as we just
need to get over that I mean I
I'm over it
I've been over it but all the right we
just need to get over that you know you
you need to get over your fear if you're
if you're deathly afraid of being called
oma phobic you got to get over that fear
because that fear is be just like you
got to get over the the fear of being
called bigoted or racist or sexist which
isn't to say that it's okay to actually
be any of those things the point is that
you can be called any of those things
even if you are not those things
obviously that those labels are used to
shut down legitimate debate and
legitimate discussion and legitimate
criticism and so you should be morally
opposed to actually being sexist or
bigoted or racist or anything like that
but you cannot be afraid of the label
you can't be afraid of people
exploitative Lee coercively trying to
manipulate you by throwing that label at
you
and in what continent when it comes to
labels being used to manipulate course
exploit and everything else homophobic
is the
one possibly second to transphobic
people are so afraid of that label for
some reason that they just many people
will let even something like this go
without without criticism what we see is
this is not a slippery slope anymore
okay we don't need to worry that all the
stuff that's going on is is gonna lead
to the normalization of pedophilia we
don't need to worry about that it might
happen because it is happening we need
to worry about the fact that it is
happening right now that we are watching
it happening there this is an 11 year
old boy dancing for guys at a gay bar
having dollar bills thrown at them that
is the normalization of pedophilia look
it's happening right now we're here it's
not a slippery slope anymore we're not
looking further down the slope and
saying oh we might end up there we are
here right now what is happening right
now pray for the country that's all I
can say and pray for this you know more
than that pray for this poor young boy
who just has been exploited for as long
as he's been alive practically and he's
he needs a lot of Prayer and a lot of
help and he's going to need a lot of
counseling once he finally breaks free
from the grip of his monstrous
despicable parents he's going to need a
lot of counseling all right finally
today as we get ready for Christmas I
wanted to settle once and for all a
discussion so that it doesn't need to
continue I'm going to give you the
definitive Christmas movie rankings okay
these are the top five best Christmas
movies in order from good to great and I
emphasize that my list is objective it
is scientific and as such it is absolute
and when I am dictator everybody will
review
required by law to affirm the truth of
this list and all infractions will be
punished by death all right
number five It's a Wonderful Life fifth
best Christmas movie classic number four
Christmas Story number three home alone
number two Charlie Brown's Christmas and
number one John Carpenter's The Thing
now that's the movie about the research
team in Antarctica being hunted down and
killed by shape-shifting alien now that
the movie technically doesn't take place
on Christmas doesn't have anything to do
with Christmas at all really but there's
lots of snow and they're also guy with
guys with beards and as far as I'm
concerned that makes it a Christmas
movie and just to settle that debate
here are the criteria to determine if
something is a Christmas movie okay it
need only meet one of these criteria
number one it has to take place on
Christmas or it can take place in the
snow so that the thing the revenant
Fargo the shining Christmas movies
number three there's a guy with a bushy
white beard so Lord of the Rings
obviously and number four if it makes
you feel merry like The Princess Bride
then it is a Christmas movie that's all
it takes to be Christmas movie or if we
want to get really technical and
Theological which maybe we should be
when it comes to what we call Christmas
films then really actually there are
almost no Christmas films at all because
an actually in order to really be a
Christmas movie right it would need to
either be a movie about Christ and about
the Christmas story or at the very least
Christ would need to feature prominently
in it and even a movie like It's a
Wonderful Life which is a wonderful
movie and I love it but Christ is is
barely mentioned that movie so are there
any actual Christmas movies there are a
lot of holiday films there are a lot of
very good holiday films but as far as
actual Christmas movies I mean you're
left with that cartoon a few years ago
about the the donkey that carried the
Holy Family to Bethlehem so that's a
Christmas
movie I think they made a movie a few
years ago about the Nativity story but
there really aren't that many there
aren't that many actual Christmas movies
so maybe instead of my idea at the top
of the show about the border security
movie maybe if Hollywood could make some
actual Christmas movies for a change and
then we could circle around and still do
the border security movie which by the
criteria I laid out would actually be a
Christmas movie because of all the snow
all right we'll leave it there thanks
for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed